huh you guys need a fix this network is  killing me  we're working on it sir I'm sorry for  the inconvenience hello welcome to the  sunshine Inn sucking in  I need you to sign your life away thank  you stupidest um you ever check into my  hotel  [Music]  [Music]  you guys said three for me  [Music]  do you guys know where the Wi-Fi it's oh  wait no money it's working video I'm  sorry  just check  instant  [Music]  what new service let's try the black bag  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  you tell me what's wrong with the  network  it's supposed to relax for the weekend  look how that turned out  it's [ __ ] Wi-Fi people you too  unbelievable you know what I'm gonna go  to the front desk and get my money back  [Applause]  some here at fix your Wi-Fi  [Music]